Speaker 1: One of the things many of you
have been writing to me and asking over the
last couple of weeks of the Russian invasion of
Ukraine has been some version of Hey David, why
do so many American right wingers love Vladimir
Putin? And this is not a topic that has slipped
the minds of many on the left who have been
wondering and asking about it. There's actually
a couple of good articles that you guys can
check out. One such article by our woman, Dawie,
is an opinion piece in the Guardian called Why
Does Putin Have Superfans among the U.S. right
wing? The subheadline, being the Russian leader,
is an autocrat with a homophobic and misogynistic
worldview. No wonder he's admired by so many
Republicans, pointing to essentially the the
governing and cultural similarities between Putin
and what many right wingers would like to see.
Robert Reich wrote in The Guardian an opinion
piece called Putin ISM is breeding in the heart
of the Republican Party. Make no mistake, Putin's
authoritarian neo fascism has rooted itself in
America. The Cold War has already come home. There
are different reasons why different right wingers
find Putin to be an appealing and
interesting figure. We saw the video,
which I'm not going to play again from the weekend
at AfPak. AfPak was the openly white nationalist
counterpart to CPAC, and at AfPak, one of
their leaders, Nick Fuentes, talked about
Russia has what Russia has going for. It is
young white men and they started chanting Putin,
Putin, Putin. And so for some people, what
they like about Putin is white, homophobic,
Trumpian, reactionary, probably anti-Semitic to
some degree leader and Putin, anti-NATO and Trump
anti-NATO up until two days ago. Remember that two
days? I mean, this is so stupid. But two days ago,
Trump started taking credit for Naito. Now that
Naito is seen as good because it's on the side of
Ukraine now, Trump after trying to crush Naito
when he was president. Now Trump says NATO's
good. But up until before two days ago, Donald
Trump and Putin both very much anti Naito. And
when you step back, Russia is sort of what many
of these Republicans would like to see the United
States become. And what I mean by that is they
like the idea of the authoritarian strongman
gets to decide who's president. I mean, that's
that's what Putin essentially does. And it's
what Trump tried to do. So that that's very
appealing to many Trump Republicans, barely any
serious worker protections in Russia, barely any
environmental protections in Russia. The rich can
get away with paying barely any taxes through
their cronies that connections to leadership.
The government just openly tells media what to
do, and they have a massive state media apparatus
that does their bidding. Trump's Trumpists and
Trump love that stuff. Open homophobia and other
phobias that in the United States, at least to
some degree, you're still kind of looked at as
that's not really appropriate if you just come out
and say a lot of the stuff a lot of. Sort of sort
of state assets that are privatized, controlled
by oligarchs and people get cushy contracts
because they're close to government, you know, all
that type of corruption and cultural reactionary
infrastructure that the United States doesn't
fully have that many Republicans would like
to see. It have exists in Russia. It exists in
Russia. You can even kind of make it even simpler.
Change would be bad, and keeping right wing
white people in control is good. I mean,
that looks like you could even simplify it even
more, and you quickly understand why there are so
many right wingers who love what is happening
in Russia. I think one other thing that's
important to mention is that not everybody in the
Trumpian Republican Party openly supports Putin.
A lot of them don't. But they'll
kind of talk around the edges about
making sure that democracy works as intended,
which remember, is the same type of code
that the Putin people use in Russia to justify
their subjugation of democracy, to control
elections. It's it's really, really similar. If
you look at the language and you look at the goals
and you look at the political orientation.
So it's a serious topic. It's not just,
oh, a lot of these Trumpists are enamored with
Putin. Yeah, some of them are, some of them not
so openly. But the degree to which Russia is the
image of what we would get here if the Trumpists
got their way, whether or not they say positive
things about Putin should really scare all of us.